[Musique]
dans notre salle au grenier à sel cette
semaine nous vous proposons pas un coup
de coeur mais cinq coups de coeur le
premier film c'est un nein tease
c'est ça se passe dans les années 90 à
los angeles
on suit un jeune un jeune garçon de 13
ans qui
qui vient peu une révolution intérieure
qui découvre le skate et la rébellion
et c'est un très beau film à l'ancienne
que je vous conseille très fortement
c'est un peu c'est vraiment notre coup
de coeur au grenier à sel
nous avons aussi dans le cas de la
semaine de l'environnement
le grain et l'ivraie c'est un
documentaire argentin sur le mode
d'agriculture en argentine et toutes les
conséquences néfastes que ça peut avoir
donc c'est le grain et l'ivraie nous
vous proposons aussi pour le jeune
public pour les enfants à partir de 6
ans royal corgis est un film d'animation
belge
avec les chiens de la reine d'angleterre
est donc son chien préféré y est
se retrouvent à la rue et il va tout
faire pour retrouver à la maison et en
chemin il va rencontrer l'amour ça
s'appelle royal cauris
nous avons aussi gloria belle avec
julianne moore et john turturro ou
le personnage de juniac bora célibataire
cinquantenaire et
et elle profite de la vie et elle
rencontre elle rencontre le personnage
de jane torteron dans la
dans une boîte de nuit et elle
redécouvre alors on découvre un peu la
vie le dernier film de la semaine c'est
les crevettes parité comédie française
sur un club de water-polo higuain qui va
faire les championnats du monde en
europe et on les suisses et c
c'est très attrayant c'est très très fou
fou et on aime beaucoup ça donc les
crocs et maïté vous retrouver tout ça
sur notre site internet cinéma grandi à
cinq points comme
[Musique]